foreign
Lake Worth Florida
which is South it's South South Florida
yes I had 40 minutes north of Miami
I split the time there in uh alapato
which is Downtown Miami I spent half the
time there with my dad so tell me about
your parents
uh my mom
out of high school she went to work for
Larry Flynt
uh that's the
Hustler magazine guy for those of you
who don't see who that is uh she Rich
she first started out as his personal
Barber because that's what she went to
school like trade school or whatever uh
and then I don't really know the ins and
outs that are how they're
relationship evolved uh whether it was
strictly platonic or not I don't I don't
really know I never asked I don't really
care but uh
she turned into quite a partier from
what other people have told me
and then Larry Flynt rented a mansion
down on Palm Beach that's how my mom
ended up in Florida she uh she became
the head mistress or the head like house
lady that all the models would come in
from all over the place and she would
make sure that they followed the dress
code which was if you come outside your
room you got to be naked
so and she had to adhere to those rules
soon
all the women that was Larry Flinch
thing all the women walk around naked in
front of them that's just his thing uh
my dad
my dad's a human immigrant
he's a dick
and uh
probably one of the coolest people I
ever knew
ah
he died last February
I didn't ever get to say goodbye or
nothing uh
little unresolved issues I guess it was
your childhood like
shitty uh bounce here bounce there uh
primarily I grew up like on the south
side of Lake Worth which is
predominantly black and Haitian I mean
they're both black uh people but
so I speak a little Creole uh
you know I joined the gang when I was 11
years old
well I I started to join the game and at
12 as my initiation I had to
put in work if you can
read between the lines
right before my 12th birthday
uh the gang that I was attempting to
become a part of is Latin Kings uh
which is
actually
on the up and up as an organization for
the most part
however just like any other organization
you've got bad apples within that group
and they create
Snowball Effect of other bad people in
the group
so that nowadays it's all bad there is
no more respect honor loyalty these are
you know the mottos that we live by
however things change
um
I started using drugs on a regular basis
smoking pot drinking
specifically uh Saint eyed special Brew
is my thing
and
I used to get drunk as hell when I was
probably like 12 13 years old and go out
and
either fight or you know I had a little
380 I'd go out and shoot people's tires
out in the neighborhood I was just a bad
kid you know like not really bad I was
just bored and I had bad influences so
it became so easy to just be a [__]
you know and uh
like I said I I kind of keep avoiding
this right before my 12th birthday
these guys my brothers
send me to go do
what I'm supposed to do in order to
become a full-fledged member of the
Latin Kings and
that was to take somebody's life
still that's over 30 years ago
and I still it was right at 30 years and
I still struggle with that [__] I still
have nightmares about it
it's not the fact that the guy died or
that I killed him that doesn't really
bother me so much as much as it does
like his family like I snatched his
I basically
killed his family too because they're
never going to be the same they're
always going to be damaged from that one
incident
you know and that's not the only time I
mean I've [__] hurt so many people
both I'm emotionally physically and I've
been hurt [__] I've been shot seven
times stabbed beat with a baseball bat
ran over all kinds of [__]
and I just keep coming back for more
neglecting for punishment
as far as the drugs concerned by the
time I was 14 I was doing an eight ball
a day of cocaine
ah
I started to dabble into the pills
oxycontins and stuff and Xanax
and before long I was hooked on that and
the coke
so I'm doing I started shooting it by
the time I'm 15.
and I'm 39 gonna be 40 in a couple
months
and I still
love shooting cocaine and heroin however
there's not much heroin anymore now it's
all Fentanyl
and you're lucky if you don't die when
you do that [__] so
it's a fine line you're using now no I'm
not presently using opiates but uh I'm
not Beyond getting high on some some
Coke or crack or whatever you know crack
is just easier to get
and you I prefer to slam it which means
to shoot it uh
so really when you get the crack you're
eliminating what makes it correct by
putting a citric acid like vinegar or
orange juice or anything with citric
acid it breaks the baking soda down like
the volcano project when you're in
elementary school you put baking soda
and pour vinegar and it makes the
volcano erupt
it's just a chemical reaction so it gets
rid of that and
that's how I do it
Johnny Cash said it best hear that
trainer coming rolling around the bend
oh it's in such an intense feeling that
I just can't even I can't describe it
and surely you can see like that excites
me and it's so sick to me like part of
me is like damn what the [__] wrong
with you
the other person's like you know what
[__] it who cares
nobody [__] I don't have nobody ain't
nobody calling and checking up on me
nobody gives a [__] you know what I'm
saying and then it helps you numb the
numb everything yeah the memory of what
you did when you were younger oh dude
when I was younger when I started going
to prison how many years you do in
prison uh well
when I when I killed that guy when I was
. they uh
they figured out some way the [__]
attorneys figured out some way to get me
off like with some I had to do a level
eight program which was like a year uh
I only ended up doing like seven months
and I escaped from there like I ran I
was in Pokey Florida which is all sugar
cane so by the time I got to a road in
some civilization I was so cut up and
bleeding everywhere that
I was literally losing blood I probably
would have died if I wouldn't know like
flagged somebody down I was bleeding
that bad I had some like sugarcane sharp
the leaves are
I I had
Thorns off glass in my feet I was all
[__] up
and uh
I don't know it's it's
hard to recall all this stuff and and
sit here and not get emotional about it
I mean huh
ah excellent
I really hadn't thought about that that
dude in so long you know how'd you how'd
you kill him
shot him in the face closed casket
made sure of it that was the requirement
uh did he do anything to bring that on
well he
he did yeah I mean this was this was a
hit you know like
he did something
but I really to this day don't know all
the details I didn't want to know all
the details I just wanted to do my part
and be done with it and be be a part of
something have a family
and that's what being a king offered me
so your family was where
[__] my mom and dad dropped me off when
I was like four years old at this dude
named Joe fair and Ellie's house it was
one of my dad's co-workers my dad was an
iron worker
slash
concrete slash whatever the [__] you do
for work to get paid cash so we could
get high every day you know
uh but uh so they dropped the parents
your parents dropped you off dropped me
off at Joe's house man and
they didn't [__] never come back
I mean who the [__] does that I got kids
I got five [__] kids and I don't give
a [__] I may have abandoned them by
going to jail
but I didn't take her their mom with me
you know what I'm saying like
I've been fortunate I picked the good
Mothers for the kids I'm the [__] up
one
but I make every effort that I can to
see my children when I can uh
I was just released from prison
literally two weeks ago
I got out Monday March 7th
I got out of Gulf Correctional and which
is in the panhandle of Florida
it's a level seven institution maximum
security
and uh
that was on the seventh yeah on the
eighth I was on a plane here I got out 5
a.m Monday 10 p.m Tuesday I was here do
you ever see your parents ever again
gee I talked to my mom a little My dad's
dead he died February 17th last year
and uh
I mean I can't say I can't say like I'm
upset about it
I guess I'm not happy about it either
a lot of my resentments and uh
things that I suppress or hold inside
that probably are the trick the things
that caused me to keep using
because God knows I'm [__] sick of
this [__] I love the feeling but I don't
like the consequences that come with it
were you using in prison
I mean yeah we sell a lot of drugs in
prison so
in the bylaws or in other words for us
and the Commandments of our
of our nation
we're not supposed to use drugs other
than if you want to smoke some weed or
drink a little bit you're not allowed to
get [__] up though it's that's a rule
and you will get you will get violated
or Worse something could really bad
could happen to you if the wrong people
were to view it and say oh well and [__]
this dude he's been in trouble for what
four or five times with us
go ahead and [__] whack them and you
never see it coming
you know it'll be your best [__]
friend come and stab split your throat
or some [__]
so it's a constant battle like walking
on eggshells constantly the politics the
[__]
and I'm a high ranking member of that
Nation
probably like in the if I was in the
Army I'd be the equivalent of like a
general or something so when you say
that Nation you're not talking to the
Latin Kings I am talking about you are
yeah 100
Latin king and queen well Almighty Latin
king and queen Nation
is the
True full name
but I mean
there's positives involved in it it
wasn't designed to be a street gang it
was designed to fight [__] up people
who would come into our neighborhoods as
Latino as Latinos and
just beat us for no reason [__] uh
come going through people's houses
stealing their money like the cops were
nasty in Chicago back in the 40s and 50s
and 60s so coming late 60s early 70s
some brothers got together and they're
not black Brothers but some some of my
brothers
we got together in Humboldt Park and we
formed
to Almighty Latin King Nation
and the queen part that comes later you
know grow and develop uh
so you're half Cuban yeah my dad's my
dad's Cuban my mom's iris is that a
requirement to be yeah you have to have
you have to be at the very least Italian
um but you can be mixed
however
I don't recommend it so whoever's
watching this don't [__] think that
if you're a half breed you can go join
these people and they're going to
embrace you with open arms it's quite
the opposite oh
just to give you an idea uh
I went above and beyond I was a vicious
just mean nasty person because I knew I
had to be
but it was all an act it was all a
facade you know I put up a [__] game
face you know like you see the football
players
they got that [__] unit on their face
they're always they're serious when
they're on that field well I had to be
serious
out there
carry a gun everywhere I go I still
right now I carry a gun you know what I
mean like what do you your prison time
that you just got out for what was that
what were you even for uh well
aggravated battery
and the [__] up thing is this
aggravated battery with a deadly weapon
and I didn't have a weapon they say that
my hands because of my martial arts so
they say that I'm my hands are deadly
weapons so unfortunately if I punch
somebody it's it's a felony no matter
what
uh I had that and possession of firearm
by a convicted felon
that was my fourth offense with that
same charge and they gave me 20 years
for that
uh I did get enough five years knocked
off
and I did 85 months
85 [__] months
and I've been out close to three weeks
it's [__] it's crazy out here I'm
[__] crazy I I think
I think that uh this last time really
[__] my head up really good like it it
15 years tore me up it was like it
ripped my [__] soul out of my body I
just didn't care about nothing or nobody
in there
thank God I got out when I did because
I would say I was a [__] borderline
ready to hang myself you know I was [__]
I still think about it all the time
because
it's easy to just give up you know who's
gonna miss me nobody I couldn't hang
myself that was just an example I'd have
to [__] swallow my gun you know I
just know I I couldn't hang myself or
slip my wrists or nothing I couldn't do
that
but I will say this and uh
and take it to the [__] bank I don't
carry a gun because I'm serious about
[__] people up out here I carry a gun
for when the day comes where the police
are going to come to me
and I know I'm gonna go to jail
at that moment
I'm just gonna pop off on the police I'm
not trying to kill him I just want them
to kill me suicide by a cop they call it
you know
hopefully it doesn't come to that but if
it does Court will be in session in the
streets I'm not I'm not going back to
prison
never again will I have a dude tell me
to squat and cough and spread my [__]
ass cheeks
it's just a [__] up place I could
I've seen so much crazy [__] happen in
prison it's uh
this is terrible dudes fighting and guy
[__] grabs another dude's nuts and
literally ripped his [__] nuts off
with no like just snatching them and his
whole set came on
that was just some that was just one
incident like it's [__] [__] [__]
and then you got these you got the
chungos the blacks you got the [__]
Hispanics in the whites
I [__] hate that try [__] effect
of separation and
I'm better than them because of this and
it's not just the white people who act
like that the [__] blacks in the
Spanish are just as guilty if not more
because they feel like they they they
deserve to get some get backs on the
lights
well
I didn't have no [__] slaves I wasn't
even around one of them [__] Rosa
Parks rode the bus and [__] I don't give
a [__] what color you are
the only thing I care about is green if
it's cash
you could be whatever gang you want to
be you could [__] as long as you're
not a kitty [__] that's one thing I
will not tolerate other than that
I don't give a damn about any personal
or any person on an individual basis
because I'm not trying to make any
friends I don't have none uh I got a few
like waiting shows that I talked to and
that's usually only because my first
night out here I [__] two dudes tried
to jump me and I beat both of them's ass
right in the middle of San Pedro
in front of probably 200 people
so now when I walk on the sidewalk
[__] gets out of my way I'm not
a bully I hate bullies
but I will I demand and respect period
and that's from anybody respectable to a
dog
everything every living thing is due
respect and these [__] people up here
in Los Angeles Skid Row Downtown
whatever are the [__] slum of the
earth dude I hate that I landed here but
I came out here for work I start my job
Monday
who knows how long it lasts who knows if
I can stay off the needle I mean I don't
[__] know
sitting here listening to me I probably
sound like a [__] nutcase but
hell I am in that case certified
should be taking psych meds but [__]
that that [__] makes you wackier than
you already are
I'm the way I am and that's just it God
doesn't give a damn he made me like this
or so they say so
if he can accept me I definitely accept
me I'm I'm okay with myself
all the other [__] is irrelevant I wish
I could live like that I wish I could
hold on to that what I just said and
live every moment like that
unfortunately it doesn't work like that
because I got a short fuse I don't even
know if I have issues I think it's just
like you light it and it just goes boom
you know immediately
uh
and it happens way too often
this guy beating beating on the [__]
woman the other day and in broad
daylight all these [__] dudes are
just watching this [__]
like I'm really seriously wanted to the
dude who's hitting the woman yeah you're
[__] up
but what's even more [__] up is all
these dudes are so-called tough guys
they're standing there [__] watching
this [__] in in the
laughing and [__]
like what the [__] kind of human being
laughs at somebody else's despair this
lady's so [__] terrified of this dude
that
she can't leave him because she just
knows he's gonna kill her which
who knows what he'll do but
I think she's far safer she got the [__]
from around there
take somebody she works take your
[__] paycheck and get on the bus or
train or something
I tried to tell her that and uh
oh no man it's just this world has gone
to [__]
and I'ma cause of some of it I'm
guiltier than most
what emotions do you go through mostly
and now you're out especially
well I can't say
any one particular
emotion overrides any other one or is
more uh more
occurs more uh
it's kind of like one one emotion will
trigger another and you know and it's
also almost simultaneously that it
happens so
it's hard to pinpoint you got anger you
got depression oh my god do I have anger
it could be something so petty like
you could be playing Spades
and you don't bid your hand right
I'm glad we'll cuss you the [__] out you
know we're partners and [__] I'm I'm
doing it because I want us to win
but I go about it the wrong way are you
institutionalized now [__] yeah dude I
still when I get up
because I I stayed the night not last
night but I stayed the night uh two
nights ago
at this this kid's house that goes to
the clinic I go to methadone clinic
that's how I'm managing to stay off the
needle right now to be honest with you
uh
150 150 milligrams of
more of uh
methadone
doesn't get you high it just kind of
Mellows you out and [__] you it
blocks The receptors a little bit not
blocks them it just kind of like covers
them a little bit with like just picture
putting a screen over a whole [__] you
can still get in there and you can still
get high if you really want to but
I just don't I don't want to you know I
don't mind doing a little
partying but doing dope doing heroin
fentanyl pills
anything that makes you [__] sick
when you don't have a Jesus Christ what
was I thinking go ahead and let these
[__] people trap me into some [__]
addiction where they're in control
and
you know it's usually black people
who are selling the drugs at least on my
way
and they just love it when a [__]
white dude is having to call in back to
back like what the [__] were you at
they love that [__] you know it's it's
just it's comical to them
so I got I got like an idea that I was
thinking about doing
kind of off what I just said but I I
just thought about it
I was thinking
get a house
and kind of like put like you got
cameras you know put cameras all over
the house like they did real world
except for we'll call it crack world or
drug world or something like that you
know you could almost take the studio
and turn it into something you know four
or five bedroom little bedrooms and put
12 people in here
the drama that's gonna unfold just think
about it you take 12 of these
[__] if you do that at any of
the hotels here down
have say it again you can do that at any
of the hotels that are yeah here in the
neighborhood oh yeah it's crazy like I
it's a great thing what they're doing
for people thank you state of California
also two days are yesterday went to the
food stamp office
gave me food stamps cash assistance
and some Medical in Florida you don't
get [__] you can get food stamps for a
month or drugs a serious charge in
Florida uh like here you just get they
let you go it depends it really does yes
you're you're going to jail if you get
caught with residue of cocaine in a bag
your ass is going to jail and you're
going to have a felony for residue now
chances are a Joe to probably throw it
out because there's not enough evidence
if you've got any kind of lawyer at all
he's gonna oh well we want an
independent test it
well there's not going to be anything
left to test no test you got to drop the
keys so
yes and no they're tough on it but
they're not at the same time it's it's
weird they pick and choose who they [__]
with I'm one of the ones that gets
[__] with because of the game [__]
uh
well I was on the front page of the Palm
Beach Post
and the way they had it it looks so
crazy because they're so far off
they thought they had me at the top
with another guy the other guy's not
even part of our group
and they're trying to say that him and I
were the leaders
of the Palm Beach and Broward chapters
and I just thought it was hilarious that
they would say that
because
I don't live there
it's kind of irking me now I'm like what
the [__] if you had your life you live
all over again what would you have done
differently
hmm
a lot man
primarily though I think
I think that would really like focus on
self-discipline
[Music]
and [__] doing right in elementary
school like listening and doing my work
but I was one of those people and I'm
still like this you could run numbers
past me
huge numbers and I can just figure them
up
same thing with uh
they'd be I'd hear them doing stuff in
class
it'd lock in my brain
I might go and read a couple little
things and then boom I I don't do any of
the work though
I don't do homework I don't do classwork
[__] that yeah great memory but I get a
hundred on every test how far are you in
school
10th grade
yeah
and that was only because I went to that
program
if I wouldn't have gone there I probably
would have I probably wouldn't even gone
to high school I could have taken my GED
when I was in sixth grade
uh
so I got a little bit of college too I
did some college classes uh
I'm actually pretty [__] smart which
is the most disappointing part of it all
I'm well spoken
smart as a [__] whip
and uh
mechanically inclined I can draw
uh I wouldn't call myself an artist but
I can do tattoos
if you put a pattern on I can do it I've
been doing that for about 20 years
so I got a lot of talents I got a lot of
[__] up [__] but I think it's about
balanced out you know like I I got a lot
of good stuff
and a couple bad things are real bad so
it's like it's tipping the scales
but I'm working on it what's your
biggest fear now that you're out
let's get what scares you the most
hmm
my reactions
your temper
it's terrifying Ozzy I'm 39. I'm born in
July I'm a cancer
and uh
if you think about it crabs right that's
the symbol for my
sign
crabs are real docile they don't bother
nobody you know they're kind of they
travel in packs or whatever but
they don't really talk you know what I'm
saying like I don't know how they
communicate but I'm just thinking they
don't right so
me if I could walk around all day and
not speak to people
I'd be okay with that I'm not really
this is probably the most I talked in
[__] five months
and I'm doing it because I'm hoping that
somebody whoever the hell is watching
this stuff
we'll take it serious and like really
listen to what the [__] me and all these
other people that have been doing this
are saying
because
trust me I'm not glorifying any of that
[__] it was a waste of time a waste of
my life
and God knows how many people were
affected by my
my negativity uh
these are things that I gotta live with
now and hopefully
if you're young enough and you haven't
made these mistakes you can
[__] learn just pay attention and do
one thing I said [__] just one thing
don't join the game
but that's that's really not that
it's not that serious
just [__] do good in school I don't
care if you fight every day after school
I don't care if you [__] smoke crack
after school just do good in school
and you will go somewhere in life I mean
they the government wants you to do it
to be successful
maybe not wholeheartedly because they
like to be in control and the smarter
you are the more power you get with
money
uh the less control they have of you so
it's kind of like a I won't go into
conspiracy [__] though that's but what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
hmm
always
be observant
pay attention
pay attention I used to tell
all right so the kings in Florida were
probably the
the largest gang in Florida
but we're like I said we're all over the
world and we all fall under the same
umbrella versus a lot of other games
they have offshoots you know Gangster
Disciples black Gangster Disciples Latin
Maniac disciples a whole bunch of these
[__] little sets
well uh
generally
give her given whatever prison you're at
uh
there's something called having the keys
to the yard which means
we're in charge of that compound
nothing gets done unless it goes through
us
it's politics
you know nothing gets done without going
to the president unless it's some snake
[__] that they're
and the same thing happens in there
people do rogue [__] and they get [__]
up for it when they get caught killed
even you know
but uh
I just think that
all of these things that I'm saying I'm
just gonna try to
get to your next question because I
don't want to keep rambling about it
I'm more of a direct to the point kind
of guy you know and I want these [__]
hopefully it's kids you're gonna watch
this and hopefully your parents don't
care that I'm cussing because I do have
a
High curse like a sailor but you know
perfect imperfections I guess um
I'm well spoken but I cuss a lot
and I'm so frustrated man because I I
want to get high bad as [__]
I fighted every goddamn day man
one of these days I'm gonna lose that
fight man if I can't get the [__] out of
here and
all I need is just a just like a little
you know how like when your little kid
your dad or your mom they hold on to the
bicycle seat in The Handlebar and they
push you for a little bit and you're
pedaling and the next thing you know
you're kind of like wobbling a little
bit and then boom you straighten out
you're free
but I just
I need that I need
somebody to help me get started you know
like
it's [__] I thought I could do it on
my own man it is [__] hard it's damn
near impossible
being institutionalized I'm used to
these [__] bringing me my food
bringing me my commissary
I got a bed to sleep in I got fans no
air conditioning I didn't have air
conditioning for 15 years if you can
imagine that in Florida
uh
wait ah man
I didn't think it was gonna affect me
like this talking about this [__] man
keeping inside for a long time no no
it's okay it's okay I'd rather I got all
the time in the world man
my schedule is non-existent if you will
until Monday Monday I start work
7 A.M till uh
7 A.M until 3 30. uh job sites in West
Hollywood so I'd like to go out there
and see the freaks you know
I've actually been thinking about trying
to get a place out there but
everything's so expensive here I mean
it's it'll [__] take me months to
save up that much money even though I
make really good money doing this job
I already know the expenses and I got
money I gotta pay back I'm trying to get
my license I haven't had a license since
2007.
hmm and I never had a moving violation
ever
so he took my license because of unpaid
Court calls
so
all right John thank you so much for
sharing your story all right well thank
you and I mean
we shoot lots of luck now you're out
thank you I've I'm uh
I pray every day man that [__] gets
better
because it's just been getting worse and
worse every day
but it's the [__] uh what's it called
uh
sometimes right before it stops raining
it'll get real bad for a second then
it'll just stop so hopefully I'm in that
real bad and then it'll just stop and
things will get better I hope so that's
what I'm hoping for you know all right
thank you all right thank you